oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle part ça pas possible d'être un
pareil pas compris il va essayer d'en
faire la malle et vas-y mentionner les
40 ans lui alors ça ce cas on apprenait
un loft qui avait 40 ans qui
m'a donné 40 ans au panier a donné 40
ans merci mais je suis beaucoup plus que
ça
merci en tout cas vous êtes une très
bonne émission
c'est dans ce moment il ya quelqu'un
qu'on adore il émit intervenants me
chroniqueur me spécialistes capillaire
mais semi-permanents deckers bertrand
deckers évidemment alors ce gars là je
comprends pas il a tous les talents il
sait chanter et danser il sait parler de
la reine elizabeth ii tranquillement
c'est l'homme aux mille facettes
regardez c'est à lui d'en tuer et on a
découvert bertrand deckers ans bertrand
deckers c'est l'homme qui pouvait
prendre la relève de guillaume canet je
veux me sentir tout contre toi sur toi
de haut en bas
que ma tumeur s'est transformé en une
perte village
mais c'est aussi l'homme qui fait
craquer la régie vous savez madame sa
grâce il porte le titre de grâce qu'ils
éduquent sa grâce va changer la vie
c'est une passade c'est un épisode la
reine s'obstine rendez vous est pris
avec la jambe fava la scène se déroule
imaginez on est sous les lambris qui les
plafonds langues il est encore l'homme
qui répond à des questions qu'on ne lui
a jamais posé là on a tous les belges
qui nous regardera et des militaires
sont par exemple reçu à laquelle la
camtel palais royal à bruxelles fait
coiffer au protocole
un protocole qui est beaucoup moins sans
que le déni des devoirs
l'homme qui danse alors qu'il n'a même
pas envie de danser nous allons boîte de
nuit mais oui je veux en bois déjà dansé
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai
[Musique]
mais bertrand des coeurs c'est surtout
l'homme qui a énormément de points
communs avec les autres chroniqueurs
vous êtes vous faisiez quoi bon d'être
chroniqueur dans tpm pu faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on adore elle adore la belgique bravo la
monarchie cyril arbaud autour de cette
table qui adore défoncer les gens y en a
plusieurs mais ya mathieu ouais y'a un
guillaume way agile mais qui qui vient
de mettre un gros taquets à delphine
toute heure c'est gilles cgil garde et
gilles verdez on comprend pas en ce
moment je sais pas si c'est son mariage
avec l'atout il a l'air un peu tendu où
à chaque fois quand vous défoncer les
gens c'est mérité cyril mais comme cegid
on a l'impression que c'est un peu
gratuit
la ville a besoin d'une petite camomille
suffit
[Musique]
il ya une semaine de proposer de faire
de faire tpm people people pardon il a
répondu qu'il voulait plus être télé 96
[Rires]
voulais me casser la gueule grill c'est
vrai je l'appelle au téléphone je me
souviens très bien et le guen agl
dix minutes ils étaient à plat rond
excuse moi mon chéri je sais pas
pourquoi c'est pas gentil mais à quoi
c'est une bonne idée de mettre les
jambes ou à la droite de cyril comme le
rallye c'est moi d'être les moins beaux
à gauche comme daniel gill oui les
fiches et mon grand père est moche que
con
non moi je suis pas méchante à mon avis
elle a rencontré quelqu'un
non mais j'y retourne au maroc et nous
emmerde
alors à la question
question gelé résumé
la question c'est est
oui a dit non tu viens dire
autant des pressions
bougeait bien les souder moi j'ai
squatté des maisons j'ai tapé des gens
avec des barres de fer
ça fait des gens parce qu'elle le
méritait un
trône et y
convergent les
[Applaudissements]
chips et ont mis à jour par le motif des
tenues
jamais dit que vous avez de la merde
dans le cerveau et j'aurais dû je le
regrette
[Applaudissements]
j'adore c'est le retour de la mi
spéciale avant de repartir witt cyril
puisque vous savez que on approche à
grands pas de l'élection présidentielle
et du coup bah alors on l'a vu et bien
les candidats ils essayent de aussi de
gratter un peu d'oseille par ci par là
pour faire des beaux meeting et du cou
et du coup les candidats et donc ils
cherchent de l'oseille et ils font des
petites pub il passe à la tv y passe au
cinéma c'est leur temps durant la vue
spécial candidat à la présidentielle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
et cette semaine on a vu jean luc
mélenchon volé la vedette à hollywood
qu'à glace et franchement ça lui va pas
mal
[Musique]
bonjour
on sait
qu
on avait également jean lassalle faire
un petit passage dans les bêtisiers de
tpm p
[Applaudissements]
on a vu notre copine anne hidalgo se
balader à paris et pour une fois c'est
plus difficile de circuler dans la
capitale au grand dam des automobilistes
insupportable pour traverser paris
aujourd'hui m 55 minutes tout ça pour
des ridicules les piétons bobos et on a
vu également de prévention face à
balla le loser
esaïe emmanuel macro est prêt on a en
exclusivité son clip de campagne
[Musique]
olé
mais enfin on a vu eric zemmour essai
s'est tenu pour son prochain meeting
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]